this morning jack thomas wolf got on a
plane and flew to port st
lucie florida headquarters of the new
york mets a few hours later he signed
his first contract
the kid from henderson nevada became a
pro it was time because he accomplished
everything he could in his hometown
it's a southern nevada baseball story
soaked
in success he's the definition of a
hometown hit
raised deep in the heart of henderson
wool blasted
basic high to their first state title in
three decades
and then with jack they went back to
back told the group that
we were special and we would do big
things and we're going to change the
culture of this program forever and
i think we have and i'm going to be a
part of this program for the rest of my
life it's gonna be a part of me
jt was just beginning he won a legion
world series repping the 702
and then became the mountain west
offensive player of the year and
unprecedented three times
at unlv putting that spot for my team
and then in order to come through like
it was just
it wasn't it's nobody could have written
it out better it's god's plan 100
wolde will tell his kids someday about
the repeat titles but wait till they see
the rebel tape
jack smacked pitches everywhere in 2021
he batted 4 29. consider there are 7
000 d1 baseball players only five had a
higher average
if i were to do in another place i think
people would still
you know relish them and be like happy
for me but we did it
for las vegas or we did it for henderson
and i still have ties in boulder city
i think it's i think it's so nice to be
able to represent all three of those
places
as much as i can the mets drafted woold
in the 12th round
he's the first rebel to be selected
since 2019
and he turns pro swinging a bat of
belief
now it's my turn to keep things in my
own hands and and make sure that it
doesn't just go to waste after
finally reaching a big milestone that i
really wanted to get to from his very
first days on the desert diamond
jack thomas thrived now the city can
follow wool
take on the world
making the town proud jack we got your
back